how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course all things relating to the MCU
today we have some really really
interesting news in regards to the
Fantastic Four now I've done a lot of
videos on the Fantastic Four lately
because a lot of news seems to keep
popping up and it really does seem like
Marvel Studios really is beginning to
start the process of bringing everybody
together and starting pre development of
the film and today we have more news to
back that up today on the John Campea
show he dropped a major bomb on his show
today he said that he has been told in
the past two months that conversations
with Joss Whedon regarding the Fantastic
Four have occurred now for those of you
who do not know who Joss Whedon is he
directed the very first Avengers film
which was a masterpiece he also directed
Avengers age of Ultron which people have
mixed feelings about but ever since then
he hasn't been that active with Marvel
Studios but John mentions and has showed
that it seems like him and Marvel
Studios are tight again and that he
thinks he's coming back to Marvel to
direct something and one thing to keep
in mind about Joss Whedon and his
relationship with Marvel Studios is that
he was their go-to guy for a very long
time he helped write different movies
write different screenplays he directed
a bunch of MCU films and if there were
ever any problems with a current MCU
film that Marvel Studios was working on
they would call Joss Whedon as John says
on a show if there was a problem Kevin
Feige would literally call up a Whedon
tell him that the Disney plane is coming
to get him they would fly him on set and
he would do rewrites on set right then
and there
so Joss Whedon has played a very
important role at Marvel Studios over
the years and he helped make a lot of
great movies and now we have a report
that apparently Joss Whedon has talked
with Marvel Studios Kevin Feige about
possibly directing the Fantastic Four
MCU debut film this will be fantastic
but what's really interesting about this
is the timing
two days ago I did a video about a
report that said John Krasinski has
recently met with Marvel Studios via
zoom meeting now obviously the role that
he would most likely be speaking to
Marvel Studios about would be mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four
not to mention everybody would truly
love for his wife to play Sue Storm as
well no doubt Marvel Studios is eyeing
John Krasinski and his wife Emily Blunt
to play the part of mr. fantastic and
The Invisible Woman
so it seems like we have a bit of
fantastic forecasting news and then two
days later we get a report that they
could possibly be talking to Joss Whedon
about directing a Fantastic Four film so
it definitely seems like things are
underway for a MCU Fantastic Four film
which of course is expected and makes a
ton of sense because Kevin Feige
did drop their name at San Diego
comic-con in 2019 so Marvel's first
family is coming to the MCU very soon
but let me know what you think about
this report would you like to see Joss
Whedon direct the Fantastic Four if not
who would you like to see direct this
film be sure to let me know in the
comments down below be sure to leave a
like for the Fantastic Four and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking
a winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers you can follow me
on Twitter for live updates and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof